yo yo gireranno con tirerà con una cosa
quando le giornate saranno perfette
l'evento sarà alle stelle
serate con varie modelle che noi
attendiamo l'estate
tornando e serene proibite in questi
frangenti ma cosa fare si voglia di
venire voglia di correre sotto i
pomeriggi a cappelli chiararia avere
feeling a fino alla fine i numeri zibe
di bionde more ed emilio bene la musica
a scuola la tipa si innamora ci
troveremo tutti al mare in discoteca
intestinal 3d ne hanno sinistra fatto
alla mala milani ma la fifa servizi nati
e di sicura farà parte della mia
compagnia si lecca se d'estate compagno
eletti che desta per la pallanuoto
guardano le tipe come si muovono io me
la guerra con comodo pietà dell'ecole le
farò con comodo
c'erano scontreranno con paraocchi e
quando aiuto
l'estate che siamo tutti l'estate state
leggermente questa estate mia sogno come
un bimbo
questa è la bellezza ritorna la voglia
di vivere di [ __ ] la voglia di passare
la sola ti fa stare con la madre in gola
è il tempo di scrivere una nuova storia
l'inverno è passato c'è una storia una
nuova che si fa avanti male solo la
libertà e te lo staff un audio archivio
chance to rule the world to mac il pacco
all the beach a go like you the show is
what i'm in you is only way that we p v
non sto a casa a calcio a guardarmi la
tv
esco fuori spacco tutto poi torno e tu
non capisci più un cazzo perché ti sei
fermato volare un miraggio cosa pisci
più un cazzo perché ti sei fermato
volare un miraggio cosa tu non capisci
più cazzo perché ti sei fermato volare
un miraggio
lo posso sentire il beat lo sento non
capisci un cazzo perché ti sei fermato a
guardare un miraggio
mamma mia mamma mia persone ciao amici
dei cup e va beh chi se ne frega chi
sempre chi se ne frega o per il fatto di
mettere questo cappello per nasconderli
poi ho guardato detto ah beh forse non
erika non lo è non lo è scusatemi
scusatemi se ho iniziato più tardi dove
mangiare dovevano triremi come le
persone ciò persone
madonna madonna di ccleaner i ragazzi
dovete iscrivervi con tutti i fottuti
account cavetti in questo momento aprile
perché poi la gente dice massima stano
lo faccio io chissenefrega lo fanno gli
altri ma il mio islam iscrizione conta
si cava non mancano tra 10 mila sono
pochissimi
la tua fa la differenza di un sacco
quindi to what we want you uomo che stai
guardando questo video o donna
o quello che sei cannes e quello che hai
tu hai un account di youtube sei già
iscritto perché sono suoi schizzi zanza
sei già iscritto
log di con altro account iscriviti li
mortacci e mia sorella comunque vi
ringrazio metti il contatore degli
iscritti
no no il contatore di iscritti li metto
solo quando arriviamo a 5.000 iscritti
che manca intanto iscrivetevi con tutti
quelli che avete tutti proprio avevo
letto questo messaggio prima perché sono
un veggente signori signori beh signori
della corte un attimo ciao sergio
iscriviti con gli account che c'è allora
oggi saluto tutte le persone perché
risente quando mi mandano i saluti ve
poi jamie saluti ti dono ok no non
saluto se vi iscrivete con un secondo
account vi saluto tutti frega niente
dunque noi ragazzi hanno veramente in
tanti oggi siamo in tanti il fatto
il fatto è che se vi scrive ste tutti
una seconda carta adesso lo annunceremo
i 5 milioni e di buttare lo speciale
signore io ringrazio gli legge per aver
fatto parte di questa colonna sonora
incredibile la strada è lunga e più dura
della guardo talpa sexy dovevo digerire
non ho digerito
va beh grazie e sheila elisa williams
signori
iscrivetevi tutti immediata continua a
quanto mancano fame vedere quanto
mancano
live sub fa vj dove ne mancano ne
mancano ne mancano prevede invece in tv
bravi braille miss che ne mancano 13
mila dai da iscrivetevi con tutti fo
raga sta volando il contatore sta
volando a cantatore sto male sto male
iscrivetevi tutti i media cut dio ma sta
succedendo non ti stiamo volando cos'è
cos'è cosa vedo
guardate che roba sto male cosa succede
sto male ma la facciamo guarda che roba
che succede
fini poi versus di serie assurdo
iscrivetevi maledetti schema voglio
vedere sto [ __ ] numero arrivare a 5
milioni stasera mette lo faccio manda
per posta lo speciale lo speciale 5.000
guarda che gesù guarda lo sto traguardo
guardalo
allora ascoltatemi iscrivetevi con tutto
quello che avete tutto tutto tutto tutto
allora ascolta un attimo io tempo fa
tempo fa e con tempo fa intendo quattro
giorni fa
cosa è successo è successo che ho fatto
un gioco
questo gioco si chiama getting hot movie
rispondere donazioni scusate però sto
cercando di questo gioco si chiama
getting over it getting over it finito
male e finito male quindi io
dovete dovete
[Musica]
dovete dirmi voi se vi va che riprovo
getting over it ci riprovo questi ghazi
perché se una persona temeraria se non
vi va
faccio rocket league con thomas a
prescindere comunque se gioca getting
over it io so delle mie qualità e quindi
so che comunque a prescindere
ce la farò a vincerlo
quindi potrei giocare comunque con
thomas anche dopo abbiamo due ore e
mezza tiriamo a mezzanotte quindi fatemi
sapere se volete che riprovo quello
fosse gioco e roche con thomas non lo
faccio non lo fa
io so che lo finisco se lo faccio però
ci metto mezz'oretta tutta quindi dovete
dirmi voi intanto chi dispone tra questa
roba capisco che cosa facciamo oggi
vediamo netting hovering keting over it
rocket rocket rocket rocket rockets
rocket rocket getting over it rock e
trovo che per altri tipi di clienti link
direi che ormai ha vinto però facciamo
così se dopo mi rompete un po le balle
andiamo proviamo a finirlo se volete se
no non fa niente come volete correre
allo specchio e saluto
vi sto scrivendo tutti a g gli account
disponibili bravo malph così si fa
grazie
iscrivetevi agli account freni ed è
donazioni a cagli iscrivetevi quello va
di più è caput come non detto
grazie criba adesso leggo tutto grazie
sari grazie laurenzo grazie denigrazione
bomber correction news channel the kills
ovvero i magi fondi subscriber ragazzi
ad un traguardo dio incredibile rega
incredibile incredibile stiamo arrivando
ad una roba abnorme non è possibile non
so come sia possibile ve lo giuro
ve lo giuro non so come sia possibile e
quel 6 che che non che manca ragazzi che
lo sapete cosa che manca manca il
sondaggio su youtube invece di
chiedervelo in chat ci vorrebbe non ci
sarebbe troppo un tasto tipo quelli di
instagram che metti lei mi arriva in
live qualcosa state votando no sarebbe
molto più figo perché non si capisce
bene che cosa
[Musica]
qual è la scelta perché ma leggo solo
getting over prima del gioco sono rocket
league
yo yo varie rei solo che iniziò a
giocare a rocket poi non lo posso
abbandonare thomas quindi all inizio
dopo iniziò prima
allora vediamo getting e ting ting
getting over it meeting over it che ti
ngo venit keting over it
leggo molti più getting over it adesso
prima del gioco pirotecnico ma è
possibile getting over
allora facciamo così facciamo così di
porto tutti e due
riportiamo tutti e due così siamo tutti
tutti contenti intanto due ore e mezza
di alive rega finisco a con prima di
mezzanotte quindi tranquilli se potete
vederla anche dopo chissenefrega tanto
dopo switch su rocktv ami solo
avvisatemi solo avvisa tom e che cibo
allora tom mi metto a fare un disco
vermi reclamano che vogliono che io
finisca keting over i caduti a volta non
ci sono riuscito
lo lo finisco tanto ci riesco te lo
prometto
anche perché lui qui l'anno scorso lario
e poi switch su rocket va bene però
tanto ce la faccio ce la faccio duro
quindi appena finisco ti mando un
messaggio e subentri così va bene dai
facciamo così tanto come si dice
dopo switch lo finisco in un'ora in
un'ora lo finisco mi metto un timer c'è
un timer simone telon timers ubs
aggiunge io ve lo giuro su quello che
volete
grazie fa vj beauty ve lo giuro su
quello che volete che prima della fine
della live
io lo finisce della live prima di un'ora
in realtà lo finisco e poi giovani frega
niente
però io vi giuro che lo finisco ve lo
giuro perché l'ultima volta sono caduto
ma ormai so farlo tutto quindi l'impegno
ce la faccio promesso dall'inizio alla
fine ho contate contate
c'è un modo per mettere il camerino
metterei subito brano
si riesce ma vi giuro che ce la faccio
più duro però giuro facciamo mezz'oretta
poi switch su rock età iniziamo con
questo peso su rocket dai iniziamo stava
benissimo
vado da zero pronti belossi io ve lo
giuro su dio ve lo giuro su dio che lo
finisco io lo so io lo so lo so che lo
faccio per come sono troppo allenato
l'ultima volta ce l'ho fatta in tre
secondi ad arrivare fino alla fine
iscrivetevi con tutti i canali che avete
nel mentre io faccio messo a speedrun ve
lo giuro
dimostrerò di quanto sono capace ve lo
dimostrerò ve lo prometto
ciara tare ciao max grazie mille
iscrivetevi con tutti gli account che
avete perché oggi si arriva a 5 milioni
iscritti è lo speciale madonna lega
madonna rega lo speciale 5 milioni di
iscritti è il video più bello di youtube
al curry wine ad che cagate questo video
è il video più bello
ci abbiamo messo tre settimane a girarlo
in una settimana a montarlo infiniti
mesi per organizzarlo il video dei 5
milioni di iscritti io non potrò mai
fare un video più bello di questo perché
ci ho messo troppo a farlo ci abbiamo
messo troppo a farlo perché non l'ho
fatto solo io ci avevo messo un sacco e
non potrò mai fare un video migliori
quest il video dei 5 milioni e la vita
se tutto va bene
esce questo sabato dipende in quanti vi
iscrivete se ci arriviamo ai 5 milioni
ma sono fiducioso se volete che ci
arriviamo
iscrivetevi con tutti i fottutissimi
account adesso
right now baby ok e io finisco sta roba
e poi smiccio su rocket promesso
finiscono sta roba e fisco e switch
primo tutti e due tra l'altro mi dovete
far sapere se questa settimana volete il
video col cane con sanno perché parlo
dico la parola cane perché molti non
sanno che si chiama san marco armi che
fa vito war cane si chiama molti lo
chiamano sempre chi lo chiama semi lo
ammazzo di schiaffi perché se non è il
nome del mio cane e sun
ok quindi chiamatelo giusto per cortesia
e bo chiudendo e scherzando la prima
parte l'ho già fatta visto gioco
ragazzi io lo finisco oggi ve lo giuro
ve lo giuro tutto su una prima ora tutto
vi stupirete di quanto sono forte tutto
getting over it subito lo finisco
immediatamente promesso allora fatemi
concentrati ecco qua già vasta parte uno
che non sa giocar la fa in un'ora e
mezza io ho fatto subito grazie anche
all the lovers grazie mancato grazie
alessandro grazie matteo buona fortuna
grazie mille grazie azzurra iscrivetevi
al canale per arrivare 5 io che oggi ci
si arriva in diretta in live
io ve lo faccio vedere che ci arriviamo
ci si arriva in diretta non me ne frega
niente mi frega niente di null'altro
siamo arrivati al traguardo della vita
ragazzi i primi in italia siamo noi la
biggest family italian family e io vi
amo per questo amo meno fa roba prova
bene
fatevi concertare un attimo perché vi
giuro che oggi lo finisco grazie fran ti
rendi conto che si sta famoso ma a me
piace dire che ho tanti amici odio di la
parola famoso non mi si addice perché
sono una persona molto timida persone
provate sono tipo ladakh polo gang cioè
che persone che comunque se la sentono
io non me la sento io sono uno che ha
tanti amici che è strano da tanti amici
perché sottili dove robo volevi
vabbè raga assisterete alla più grande
speed run di youtube italia di di
getting over ben wifi vj stavo
scherzando su accaduto però la farò
oggi lo finisco con te per i dio è
entrato e ripeto lo finisco nè non ci
metto tutta la live metà live e lo
finisco ad altra metà gioca rocket
quindi tranquilli state qua per un
pochissimo lo vedrete finito sta roba
lo vedrete finito ve lo prometto
comunque visto che molti di voi mi
chiedo mi saluti noti saluto solo se ti
iscrivi contro account poi me lo dici
solo se ti iscrivi controcampo il
discorso adesso poi finisco st parte qua
ogni check point arrivo vedo quanti
iscritti siamo arrivati ok check point
c'è poi mentale perché non esistono
check point o gioco
molti di voi mi hanno chiesto ma dopo la
scorsa live che in getting over it sei
caduto cosa è successo se lo dicessi non
ci credereste ho rotto la batteria della
videocamera perché io ho la batteria
della videocamera che si attacca la
corrente e quando sono caduto l'ultima
volta gli ho tirato una dopo che ho
stoppato gli ho tirato una manata
fortissima e mi si è rotta la batteria
della videocamera infatti non ho potuto
fare video ieri perché non avevo la
batteria della videocamera totale di
comprarla tutto questo of offre video
cioè nel senso non si è visto molto bene
ho rotto e una batteria per niente
almeno le views mango una volta rompevo
le tastiera una nova sole view grazie
emma grazie a malia iscrivetevi con
tutti gli account di youtube che avete
perché quanto è vero iddio arriviamo a
cicli scritte vis forno lo speciale
della vita no ragazzi ma voi qualsiasi
cosa vi immaginate perché poi tutti si
immaginano momenti epici no omegle non
lo speciale di quest'anno in un non so
neanche come descriverlo è una cosa
impressionante non lo riuscirò mai più a
fare perché è assurdo velo troppo così
laica bombe appena arriviamo a 5 milioni
intanto siamo arrivati qua
vedo come me la sto destreggiando molto
easy è una sfida ancora di oggi tra
questa parte che ogni volta un casino
tra un attimo a parco schifosa che
d'onda giocare a roque clip forza
finiamolo sto gioco maledetto stupido un
attimo scusatemi lega mi devo
concentrare st parte studiate nato io
sto un attimo zitto che sta parte qua è
un casino
però ce l'ho intanto iscrivetevi che poi
controllo al controllo il counter
signori quota pro gamer ho fatto in tre
minuti quello che nei primi video lì che
ti ngo verità ho fatto in tre episodi
ottimo ora no ho fatto un salto orribile
ok grazie a maria grazia e giulia miss è
riuscita con tutti gli account che avrò
grazie grazie sisters
grazie mille sei troppo gentile davvero
iscrivetevi con tutti gli account che
avete perché siete a un siamo un passo
dal raggiungere il traguardo secolare di
5 milioni di traguardo leggendario cioè
i ragazzi io quando iniziato youtube
pensavo che non si potesse andare oltre
il milione di iscritti perché eravamo
come faccio non saper fare la parte che
ho fatto da parte della scala che è
molto più difficile perché eravamo in
pochi youtube italiano quindi ho detto
vabbè tanto al migliore non ci si arriva
mai siamo arrivati a casa se malati a 5
boh
vabbè se ci dobbiamo ancora arrivare
però iscrivetevi questi account che
avete e ci arriviamo forza tu che non lo
stai facendo perché sei pigro come lo
schifo fallo mannaia retta e costa ok
fallo e ci arriviamo mannai averci forno
lo speciale farm in attivo
faccio schifo mi devo concentrare che
abbiamo finire questo gioco se lo
finisco voglio vedere il counter
esplodere
pertanto il globo tanto lo finirò me lo
sento oggi è la giornata sì proprio sono
carico partito guarda lolli vuota pro
gamer oggi ragazzi mi sento di un carico
che non avete idea oggi sfondo qualsiasi
cosa
oggi sfondo tutti i caldi in 5 milioni
che ti ngo avere tutto finisca tutto
finisca tutto finì infatti so caduto li
mortacci mia dei mie parole però va beh
oggi finisco tutto promesso allora fai
le cose fatte bene
siediti mi concentro un secondo rega
scusatemi iscrivetevi con tutti gli
account che avete madonna vengo lì
vengono fatte vengo libero giuro vengo
lì vi scrive mi metto le mani al
computer mi scrivo io poi vostro account
uno per uno vuoi vedere che voglio
vederlo voglio vederlo esplodere
soprattutto counter maledizione famiglia
delle quattro stop appena arrivo che ha
sopra di pallone orange e vediamo quanto
stiamo ok vedere il counter implodere in
se stesso o fatemi conciata fatemi
concentrato savana ok ok ok
e se vi fa capire quanta vita sociale
oggi riesco a fare sta cosa troppo bene
c'è troppo bene poi faccio schifo
dissolvere la parte più facile però
bene ora in gel pregiati terminati per
questa parte quando la sua fare che è
facilissima cosa c'è che non va city ho
molto bene grazie matteo grazie lucrezia
ci siamo iscritti ontani tarapia tapioco
non so chi siano ma se sono tuoi amici
mi va bene anche che ti chiami gertrude
basta che ti iscrivi al canale ragazzi
che non sfonda restò traguardo di 5
milioni immediatamente ma non dicevano
che gli iscritti non volevano più che ti
devo mazza o riccardo 27 addirittura non
c'era bisogno grazie alla se ti iscrivi
sono contento non c'è bisogno delle
donazioni alte giuro
sono contento così basta che arriviamo
ai 5 milioni io sono contento altre
donazioni contenute allora siamo allora
in gel
ora basta devo farmi fatevi contro il
counter sono sto sudando fatevi
controllare il count adesso controllo il
counter
what the fuck ma vero
oddio no dai youssef ma no non ce n'era
bisogno giuro davvero non ce n'è bisogno
non è che io sto qua stop è iscritti in
me frega niente
grazie non c'era bisogno giuro stavo per
controllare il caos per me arrivano 200
pam
sì non c'è davvero non c'era bisogno
giuro non ce n'è veramente bisogno
fermate veramente gradi grazie perché
veramente 6 supergentile grazie ma non
ce n'è bisogno sono tanti cioè io non
sono per secondo te preoccupà grazie
però molto gentile però non ce n'è
veramente bisogno di così tanto troppo
grazie mille gas il cardo fatemi vedere
il count siamo arrivati a 86 non si
spera nativo che vedo porca vacca siamo
arrivati a 988 mila e 623 sta salendo di
brutto regalo abbiamo fatto 2 mila
iscritti in tre secondi dai check up il
live cioè create account di google
iscrivete ci arrivano in like us i 5
milioni di mortacci mia dyer ci
arriviamo
ci arriviamo ai 5 milioni in live
diretta siamo mancano 10 mila stamattina
mancano 5 mila adesso ne mancano 10 mila
siamo arrivati siamo arrivati siamo lì
daje regà daje regà ci arriviamo
ischitano tutti gli account grazie alla
tarie let's go grazie riccardo molto
gentile
allora è il momento ragazzi ora in gel
questa è la parte più difficile di tutto
getting over it 6 pronti
[Musica]
grazie riccardo molto gentili scrivete
vico tutti a cannes che rete grazie
mille molto gentile molto molto gentile
io vada fatevi concentra st parte e
fatemi concentra un attimo grazie alla
dariel chiaria la tipa che ti piace
thank you so much mai state di
concentrare casa parte devo stare
silenziosissimo o il microfono quando
sposta molto bene dai e non la sentono
lo sento
e difficilissimo da me lo sento allora 1
video concentrare scusatemi se sto un
attimo il sito sta parte impossibile se
non mi concentro non fate il tifo contro
imeva ammazzo
chi sta descrivendo con tutti gli
account e rete no perché me lo merito
non so se si è visto poi che la
punturina attenzione il counter signori
puoi vedere il counter voglio vedere il
counter salire 10 incappa mancano
maledizione di civili skeet in live e li
facciamo i 5 milioni create account
iscrivetevi fate tutto day tutto fate
mancano 10 mila iscritti e ci siamo ci
siamo ci siamo ci affacciamo ce la
facciamo sono carico schede con tutti
gli account khaled vai così grazie lollo
grazie però grazie mille che che visto
che ci stiamo unendo tutti così tanto
siamo 30.000 the facts scena gli
spettatori 30k a quest'ora il thank you
se tutti quanti ci prendessimo i tasti
iscritti saremmo già arrivati però vabbè
raga
siamo arrivati a questo punto è quanto
in quattro fatto in 45 minuti
io alzo le mani ma ocado perché me la
sto tirando troppo però sono stato bravo
fino qua vado dai forza sia con noi o
forse quando voti la supporter e noi ci
proviamo
non mi ha fatto che gara addosso perché
ormai lo so no cavolo dai che fatta dai
sporca o lei signor i signori un what a
player e ci siamo siamo in dirittura
d'arrivo 50 per cento e fatto è ora fino
alla montagna è tutto più facile
dell'inizio all'inizio è più difficile
dalla fine secondo me fino all'ammontare
di tutto molto crisi perché non puoi
cadere più giù di quanto aiuta fatto
quindi ottimo dove arriva alla fine
possa seriamente diventare uno speed
runner visto gioco ma io l'ho giocato
talmente tanto grazie david è molto
gentile saluti dalla svizzera può
iscrivere tutti gli svizzeri che c'hai
con amici
immediatamente grazie mille molto
gentile
siamo così tanti spettatori che è
successo stasera batte faq a sarà lille
angel estate di sottofondo probabilmente
sono stata quella certa parte qualche
sempre in casinò però almeno non posso
credere più di così ragas lo finiamo
siamo qua dall'inizio l'ho fatto
guardali guardalo guardali grazie peace
and love and aliens sfera quattro gli
fine ha fatto se non agonisti di marchi
di cartone cielo in cantina perché si
era un po stropicciato e proprio da un
sacco di spazio grazie francesco molto
gentile
daje daje perfetto no stanno cascando di
un raga
ci siamo
il wigan
guarda che giocatore che giocatore è che
giocatore è
a quanto siamo mi sto affermando ogni
tot perché sono bravissimi con tra gli
iscritti 10k che mancano raga dovete
iscrive con tutto maledizione stata
esplorata non ho mai fatto
possiamo tra oltre arrivare a 5 milioni
che sarebbe un record incredibile
arriviamo a battere record di iscritti
in un solo giorno lo sto facendo stiamo
facendo tantissimi record di iscritti
non solo giorno il mio è incredibile non
avevo mai fatto così tanti scritti in un
giorno grazie davvero
vi dirò di più oltre allo speciale se ci
arriviamo anche entro stasera
entro o domani anzi dopodomani video con
con sun promessi ma se dovessi morire o
prometto lo giuro su tutti gli iscritti
se non è vero potete bisi scrivermi prof
ve lo giuro che così grazie mille
riccardo grazie emanuele grazie baguette
grazie laura grazie your new world your
own words ci vogliono i baci
meritatissimi ma cento
non ci siamo ancora arrivati stavo
scivolando stava scivolando riley è
scusato e stava leggendo le cose
riccardo molto gentile davvero basterà
più ti prego iscriviti piuttosto
iscrivetevi con tutti gli account
se un battendo record assurdi stasera
assurdi live del secolo
vado sbaglia la fondatezza
quel salto è difficile mi giustifico è
molto difficile ogni volta non sai se
prenderlo troppo poco e troppo troppo ma
il cd arrivo in un secondo tranquillo
però quel salto il secco il salto del
pupazzo è sempre un problema sempre
stato un problema
meno male che siamo latini non so perché
così edificio quel maledetto l'altro non
so mai come farlo raga sto battendo che
ti ngo dritti in mezz'ora
mai successo incredibile 30.000
spettatori why
cos'è successo grandi grazie iscrivetevi
con tutti gli account che avete mannaia
mm possino a narcos tipo ciao fasci
fasci può fidare facilità siamo alberto
ciao alberto
grazie mille il supporto molto bene ce
l'abbiamo fatta
torniamo li 30.000 spettatori by non
rispettate gli iscritti importanti
iscrivetevi
iscrivetevi con tutti ma è chi account
nel mentre che arrivò la fiat secondo me
non so se arrivano prima i 5 milioni o
prima io finisco sto gioco però secondo
me sono più bravo io giuro
perché oggi me la sento oggi me la senti
appena sono entrato il live del gruppo
finirlo parco schifo che le scivolate
che tiro sono in dirittura d'arrivo per
una sfida si riesca a prendere bene i
punti che faccio ma le posso farla
sfiderà
grazie riccardo dio ti prego basta
frenate troppo troppo gentile però
bastate prego piuttosto iscriviti al con
mille account più contento grazie mille
comunque sei gentilissimo non c'è
bisogno così tanto anzi basta
ti prego davvero troppo
sarò l'unico streamer del mondo e dice
basta donazione l'unico però davvero non
ce n'è bisogno cioè mi sento sempre un
po in colpa tra virgolette quando è
troppo
grazie leo molto bene a me basta che me
li scrivete che gratis che che me frega
create account iscrivetevi gustiamoci
mannaia morte
tagliamo a 5 milioni sfondano lo sto
traguardo prima che finisco keting o
veri a nuova devi concentrarti st parte
difficile per cortesia
dov'è che è stato pazzo sta lì
o no ok l'ho preso
[Musica]
ragazzi mi sto concentrando un secondo
grazie mille junior world grazie laura
ghazi riccardo te prego frenate riccardo
ti prego basta
va be so contento grazie davvero
gentilissimo ti prego basta troppo
iscriviti sono più contento mi se ciao
asia si mettono gli abbonati mese
prossimo
perché ho in mente delle features da
aggiungere trasferta temi concentrato
grazie mille con questi si scritta con
l'account della scuola avete un account
secondario logato le scritte del mio
canale arriviamo un miliardo di iscritti
no veramente cerami 51 in questa sera
esplodo di contentezza ovviamente so che
gli haters ci sperano i mille ragazzi
siamo sul finale
vi dico solo questo in in quanto neanche
mezz'ora 25 minuti non è vero sono scemo
no dai rossetti o che deficente ero al
secchio porco schifo l'aido devo farlo
in 30 secondi speed run che pirla che
pirla incretino ragazzo che pirla ero
arrivato al secchio che è stupido porca
vacca che stupido ragazze ci arrivò in
così poco tempo carico il video proprio
come video normale cioè haifa getting
over it in 20 minuti o farà un miliardo
di business con parma non penso ci siamo
però siamo alla fine regala alla fine
arrivò la con l'arrivo al secchio poi ce
l'abbiamo fatta
c'è un miliardo di spettatori secondo me
perché non ci credeva nessuno
secondo detto la beffa getting over it
non ce la farà mai e invece e invece
siamo già qua
anzi se non avessi fatto la pirla tale
secchio saremo già praticamente al 90
per cento del gioco
avrei praticamente quasi già finito ma
sono stato scemo io sono caduto
scusatemi mea culpa su scemo però
sicuramente adesso lo faccio promesso
adesso sono un po in eccitazione un po
per gli iscritti ripete iscrivetevi
tutti account che avete che abbiamo 5
milioni
lo speciale la è la cosa più bella della
vita e in più se riesco finiamo che ti
poverty malo fini su sicuro rosso fiero
cioè nelle nei prossimi dieci minuti si
spera quindi state connessi perché i
prossimi dieci quindi saranno secolare
per il mio canale sia per gli iscritti
sia per getting over it vai tac wright
dai porcos tipo l'aido fottuti spigoli
da lei allora dài concentrato
[Musica]
speriamo che thomas mistica guardando
che mi stavo aspettando prima vista se
mi stai guardando tom hai visto che era
per un buon motivo che ho fatto che ti
ngo verità perché quando uno se la sente
se la sente da oggi me la sentivo
tantissimo se stai guardando tom batti
un colpo
porca vacca morta ma perché non riesco a
riva ogni volta faccio starò lo aspetta
dai porca di una bacca morta
ok
vabbè vabbè iscrivetevi con tutti a
cantare te lo ripeto la millesima volta
nel caso aveste capito
arriviamo a 5 rispondiamo tutto
rispondiamo tutto youtube non solo i
tubi tale traguardo così è mondiale
veramente ragazzi ci siamo
grazie riccardo basta del reg
se va bene così ti supplico esterna
grazie grazie
basta basta davvero bastano mo serio e
basta ti prego
va bene così giuro sono contento ma
basta grazie però bastano
siamo a ragazzo al cara 9000 iscritti 9
mila iscritti ho iniziato la legge ne
mancavano 15000 e 14000 scusatemi
ne mancano 9 mila 9000 noi finiamo
starai perché siamo a 5 milioni le gambe
lo faccio vedere in diretta indiretta
perfetto ma deve concentrare attimo
grazie laura
che aspettate che mi devo concentrare st
parte su un caso di nuovo una pigna 9000
iscritti mancano lega scrive dei con
tutti gli account e avete tutti li
voglio anche l'account del nonno che usa
gmail very good
prima come ho fatto a cadere qualche
pirla aspetta secchio 9.000 iscritti ai
5 milioni
raga iscrivetevi maledizione iscrivetevi
tutti tutti iscrivetevi tutti al canale
prima che arriva alla fine voglio vedere
il counter che non so se arrivo prima e
alla fine o il counter dai 5 milioni
però è una gara tra me e voi
iscrivetevi nel frattempo che ci
arriviamo guardalo il secchio ceche
salto a destra ho fatto orribile
ho allora serpente oggi siamo in pausa
poi potrai continuare a mietere vittime
ma oggi devo fare 5 milioni iscritti
mente di vista affermo devi stare fermo
oggi devo fare 5 st inferno di vista
deve esistere non esisti che non esiste
bene
ragazzi se posso secchio siamo sul
finale finali che ti muovere tutti i
venti minuti ci siete
dai no con schifo c'ero arrivato
rifacciamo ragazzi siamo ci siamo vi
state prendendo male che ci sto
riuscendo grazie riccardo basta te prego
basta va bene basta dove tantissimi
auguri per i 35 non sono ancora arrivato
se non vi iscrivete però grazie mille
ragazzi madonna che buste di iscritti
incredibile non hai avuto i miei scritti
così tanto in un giorno stiamo battendo
il record state facendo la storia tra
l'altro poi quando dirò quanti iscritti
avrò fatto in questa giornata cui nello
speciale no
i vostri scritto fa la differenza perché
se vuoi solo vi iscrivete quel numero
più alto di uno quindi quel numero se
sarà tipo 6.515 iscritti in un giorno
se vi iscrivete oggi sarà 6.516 quindi
io dirò un numero in più per merito
vostro
quindi grazie a tutti quelli che lo
hanno fatto fate parte della storia ci
siamo secchio e andiamo a fine starò
subito così veloci no grazie mille e
look up with a second che devo prendere
parte
cioè che stiamo facendo la storia
stasera incredibile ma i fatti così
tanti iscritti in un secondo ma colpi di
piper giustizieri se però non cado giù è
meglio soprattutto l'incredibile non
gioca molto bene questo è un bel punto
non è vero perché devo andarci aspetta
porno ska di una vasca è difficilissimo
perfetto lo saldato ottimo
ciao elisa grazie mille
grazie mille ragazzi l'attrice mi sto
soggetto ma stop mi sto concentrando
[Musica]
porca di una bacca è difficilissimo
esiste un corso per avere due ministri
tigrati cioè cosa dite nomads io non
faccio ste cose
grazie mille ma non so proprio il divo
[Musica]
dobbiamo essere tutti noi se non ha
senso quello che stiamo facendo quanto
vale un traguardo del genere niente
non è vero
porca la merda quanto stiamo quanto
stiamo porco demonio morto porco quanti
ne mancano non arrivarci prima io di voi
quanti ne mancano quanto tempo perso
porca vacca morta schifosa col secchio
infame lercio secchio lerci simo
schifoso di un secchio maledetta giorni
che si è pagato il counter rega 8.000
iscritti mancano 8 mila iscritti al
traguardo dei 5 milioni incredibile
incredibile arrivo prima io di voi è
difficile
vi giuro non saprei dire se arrivate
prima voglia salivo prima io non lo so
ma mi sto veramente impegnando porca di
una vaccamorta il secchio vi pare che
sono andato sui vecchi un deficiente
deficiente rega un deficiente come ho
fatto andar giù che pirla ce la faccio
prima io non lo sento dove arriva
ricicloni prima cielo arrivare devo
arrivarci prima di
devo finire getting over it prima di
arrivare a 5 milioni perché non posso
festeggiare 5 milioni mentre sono su
getting over it capito non avrebbe senso
quindi devo muovermi dai guai
come ho fatto a cadere col secchio che
pirla che pirla era facilissimo dai che
la terza volta che sono salito su sto
punto ma soprattutto breve i trequarti
vai via grazie mille ragazzi molto gt
poi leggo tutti escono un po concentrato
daje regà daje regà daje regà grazie
crixia iscrivetevi con tutti ma
direttissima account che avete sfondiamo
il traguardo 5 milioni schiti manca
niente
ne mancano 7 mila dai e no
ok scusate un attimo
vi faccio vedere in live perché me li
merito questi 5 milioni lo faccio vedere
come lo finisco sta roba
ve lo faccio vedere già arrivare fino a
qua in 20 minuti è stato assurdo poi qua
ci sto mettendo molto di più per questa
parte difficilissima però ve lo voglio
far vedere quanto meli merito allora
no minchia che kakà sopra lennon
serpente iscrivete con tutti ma
lentissimi account che avete madonna
ragazze ci arrivò prima io
se vi flacco sul tempo prima di 5
milioni merito la vita aggiustiamo spero
che cio lanza sudando grazie riccardo
sciolan sissi ma tanto manca senza
descritti qualche cosa temete iscritti
mancano sette mila iscritti
cavolo sia devo fare minchia che ansia
ma c'è paura c'è veramente mancano sette
mila iscritti non si no allora il mouse
iniziato a dare problemi a spettacolo
riavvio riavvio gioco ogni il mouse il
suo gioco ha una certa da problemi non
capisco il perchè giuro non muro a una
certa diventa scemo
anche lo chiamo altera così a è stato
via via un attimo gioco ho riavviato ok
ecco qua ma si è ripreso un po
grazie mille ragazzi mobile go tutti in
attimo può iscrivere anche samuel tuo
cane già iscritto rega è già iscritto si
scrive con tutti gli account cavetti ci
siamo siamo al traguardo ci siamo ai 5
milioni manca niente
fai una maledizione siamo lì siamo lì si
no cavalca la donna rega che grazie
mille régard troppo troppo troppo che
ammazza la spezia è bella ma lo sapevo
già
grazie baguette perché non ti a guy
perché sua madre veramente brutta e sta
in autostrada
madonna stavo facendo una fine
pessima porco lo schifo terra ragazzi ci
siamo ci siamo in salute quella buona
sei un porco schifo state buoni boni nye
e la morte mannaie la morte allora piano
dai zio
dai che ce la fai ma perché adesso
scivola sul secchio prima non scivolava
che è successo non mi lancerò mai così
c'è una paura no no mi lancio così ecco
esatto esatto dondolati bello dai se va
bene lo pigliano può essere un cecchino
è il secchia veramente difficile
grazie riccardo ciao dal bomber ti seguo
da quanti iscritti grazie oggi
raggiungiamo un traguardo incredibile
altro che 50.000 siamo tutti qui riuniti
il matrimonio matrimonio un po numeroso
quantomeno merito se lo finisco solo
finisco ci siamo schifo eccolo no cav h
dai ma perché non riesco a farlo più
l'ho fatto prima è che siamo alla fine
manca niente ma anche ragazzi fatto il
secchio e fatta praticamente manca solo
il pezzettino finale della montagna
ormai sono skillato è solo il secchio
che è difficile allora serie arrivo
dov'ero prima con legno ce la faccio se
l'arrivo arrivo davvero prima ce la
faccio ce la faccio me lo sento
iscrivetevi con tutti account e avete
mannaia ce la faccia ce la faccio ce la
faccio
ok no che pirla o va bene dai
ok ho fatto cose ho fatto cose ma va
bene ho fatto cose strane non fa niente
fame rivali ok aspetta che arrivò qua
sopra e mi fermo un secondo olè per
becco aspetta che noi faremo secondo
aspetta nelle forme un attimo voglio
lavarmi le mani le mani sudate
siamo alla fine se non lo finisco mo me
ne vado
me ne vai scrivetevi con tutti i
fottutissimi ti giuro sono alcuni voi
non l'ha ancora fatto ma mannaia guarda
tornano ora che lo ripete iscriviti col
tuo secondo account di terzo quarto
quelle che c'hai di lupi iscriviti in me
lo sto meritano me lo sto meditando più
di chiunque al mondo
altro che campagna elettorale questo gli
iscritti mato rimangano 6.000 seimila
iscritti devo fare la montagna
fatemi lavare le mani arrivo che
associamo sudate arrivo
dai dai
tutti i culi dobbiamo fare i culi i culi
signori
very good
no allora ripartiamo da li passiamo
soggetto ci siamo allora in testa un
casco
no no
madonna rivolta che slitta mikako
addosso ma c'è una tecnica per forza
montagna maledetta asta che ripassiamo
rega to die e ma c'è una tecnica
veramente per passamontagna perché no mi
chiami sono fermati in tempo il mio
telefono mi ha detto
via tutto dopo togli microfono via porco
lo schifo terra ma perché non riesco a
tirarmi su
devo andare deciso proprio palo
wow grazie play gamer let's go youssef
non ce n'è bisogno davvero
grazie però grazie mille
grazie davvero troppo gentile tenevo
basta
mancano sette mila iscritti ai [ __ ]
iscriviti piuttosto contanti a caso
contento trovo molto più indietro
[Musica]
grazie grazie ai ministeri tra
riconosciuti pensavo che eri una ragazza
anche io lo penso a tutto grazie molto
gentile let's go
andiamo sul finale vediamo questi
scritti lei mi richiamo tutti quanti al
primo all'ultimo
il finale di getting over it
avrei voluto cercare un tutorial per cui
è partita la roma non sarebbe logico
preferisco quella per i cavoli miei
piuttosto non cinesi piccola montagna
no che salto brutto perché alle volte
perché se notate le volte si incastra il
martello alle volte no non c'è un motivo
se ci sono dei punti in particolare dove
lo può incastrare altri punti dove lo
nuovo incastrare però
era buono quest'altro dai minchia no no
no moto
minchia che kakà se cadevo giu se cadevo
giu rega mamma mia che cagà era una cosa
orribile adesso non adesso proprio non
adesso mai porco schifo da una botta di
culo una volta dai e per i 5 milioni
famolo famolo fa volo che successo cos'è
cosa reggio cos'è sta roba
non era mai successo vabbè ecco appunto
cos'era successo mi era mai successo sta
cosa fate
è veramente rischiato ragazza ho
veramente rischiato veramente tanto no
ma per chi è perché caso sempre così ma
tu che cosa orribile rega iscrivete con
tutti accanto che avete manca pochissimo
arriverò prima io al finale che vuoi e 5
milioni però ci devo provare cioè almeno
non lo so se sarà così ma ci devo
provare chiama quanti siamo in stalla ed
un miliardo e mezzo che se succede cosa
succede se prende il serpente voi non
vorreste mai saperlo
va bene era risolta
no
[Musica]
perfetto daje costa montagna daje daje
alzate tutti le mani al cielo regga nel
momento questa è quella buona
no no no ok
non è vero ma posso mai essere così
cazzo sfigato posso mai esserlo che mi
si è impigliato il martello nel legno ma
cribbio ma neanche far male anche se ci
riprova un miliardo di volte mi si
impiglia in quel legno lì che sfiga
barbina proprio ma neanche se ci riprova
un miliardo era più difficile è più
difficile finire fare così che finire il
gioco cioè per farvi capi quanto
impossibile quello che appena successo
ma neanche se ci riprovo miliardo di
volte mirim pigoli ai daje daje questi 5
milioni dai e iscrivetevi gli account
che avete ci arriviamo può ma teorica
e va beh no
macchia
chi ha inventato quel legno io lo
strangolo porca vacca lo strangolo vivo
che cosa minchia serve tranne parchi
cadere giù non posso provare col secchio
di arrivare direttamente alla montagna
come fanno gli speed runner maledizione
no no no no ma perché è cristian come ho
fatto cribbio
ero arrivato porco demonio morto
si vabbè
dice che salta cos'era sta roba
il secondo ragazzo concentrato devo
usare la stessa tattica che uso quando
faccio cosa della scala la stessa mi sta
innervosendo mi devi due orbite
lol va bene zio tranquillo che che che
adesso avrai soddisfazione
sfida a fare da cui superman challenge
non so di cosa si tratta poi sguardo
raga mancano quanto manca il lanciato il
telefono prima
quanto manca e 5 mila i siti non lo so
manca pochissimo
finisco il gioco e vedo se siete
arrivati prima o poi ai 5 milioni o io
che ho finito iscrivete intanto tutti i
canali che avete qualsiasi pure tubize
let's go anzi fa vedere una roba invece
di passare dalle famiglie ma fammi
vedere sti teheran getting over
voglio vedere come lo fanno la montagna
i conigli sfide che ci mettono niente
vediamo attimo
e fanno ice monte nebo strano la gente
non so come cavo lo facciano possibile
quello che vi ho fatto vedere uno speed
runner e cioè quello che quelli che lo
abbiamo scritto quel giorno e notte per
tutta la loro vita quindi non so come
abbia fatto ma lui l'ha fatta quindi la
facciamo anche noi
se lui l'ha fatta perché io non dovrei
perché io che ho 5 mila iscritti non
posto ma mica più lascia lo speed run e
ora c'e la sfida
stavo andando più lasciato sfida se non
fossi caduto all'ultimo coso
daje daje daje
sì sì ce la fa a casa da parte il
carrello signori the power of the
internet a me 5 milioni now
ci siamo sul finale ancora lui quanto
stiamo lì scritte devo vedere
compostiamo questo il finale l'antenna
siamo all'antenna siamo l'antenna regalo
lanciato il telefono era finito in
salotto come ho fatto a prato iniziato
non impossibile
vi giuro come ha fatto figli quanto
siamo o mio dio
quanti iscritti mancano quanti iscritti
o per per fare questa antenna prima
linea dei 5 milioni mica sto sudando ho
bisogno di te perché internet non carica
quando serve perché non carica internet
non li vedo poi si è pagato tutto si è
pagato tutto le miss e pagato che ci fa
temere the life ne mancano esattamente 6
mila ce la facciamo prima
ce la faccio mi sa che ce la faccio se
non lo so dipende seccato adesso no
mi impegnerò tarraga siamo arrivati alla
fine di katie couric incredibile
incredibile c'è un'ansia che non avete
idea non iniziava non iniziamo fanno le
cose fatte bene non iniziamo ma porco
ma fate che c'è una latenza più assurda
non sono io che sono studio azzurro in
questo punto di katyn gabricce più
latenza del telecomando sede del
martello immaginate un gattini poveri
dove ci sono io col telecomando a un
ragazzo che ti fatto l'ex dj qishan
ti saluto tema anzi devo vederlo non
l'ho visto grazie mille
però giro un'occhiata tedesco minchia se
non mi agganciava il carrello devo
capire che cosa sbaglio perché se
capisco che cosa sbaglio ho finito il
gioco in una live quanto in un'oretta
lapidi sommesso se lo finisco devo solo
capire che cosa sbaglio perché con sulla
montagna non c'è niente di difficile e
non capisco perché non riesco
perché la gravità già influenza ma
facciamo tipo ok
[Musica]
perché non ti sei agganciato perché c'è
problema avevi demonio porco morto
ragazza parte vi sta veramente facendo
innervosire giuro
e lui il finale di questo [ __ ] gioco
del demonio incarnato nel nell'essere
umano in una pentola e il finale di
questa rodi questo a me va di gioco è
l'ultima cosa da fare e se non ci riesco
io me ne vado
e l'ultimo ostacolo non è neanche il più
difficile un'antenna vi rendete conto
che tipo di secchio e sei volte piu
difficili sta roba che la montagna lo è
10 volte vi rendete conto di quanto fa
ridere questa parte il confronto a
quello che ho fatto è perché io questa
non riesco a farla che il finale del
gioco mi fa troppo nervosi e sarà belle
che ho finito io ho finito il gioco
fitto che poveri se riesco a fare
[Musica]
si arrivò alla fine come minimo e fate
tutti un altro account e vi iscrivete di
nuovo come minimo nel merito se ci
arrivò solo se c'è più
giurista parte porco dem atto da me
vinchio d'asti suo martello va dove
vuole lui
ve lo giuro anche l'altra volta era così
ma non sono scemo io ma è proprio il
martello che c'è qualcosa che non va
alla fine è proprio su minchio eppure
quando il lavoro finito la prima volta
non era così un anno aggiunta sta cosa
che il martello sismiche al finale
guarda dove cazzo ma chi ce l'ha mandata
a destra calmati grande occhio ha detto
di fare per niente così e toiba tosi
però calmucca non facciamo relax finale
questo è il finale facciamolo bene mi
attacco al cosa li bene ma ti devi
attaccare non ti ho chiesto di fare
questo tu hai fatto questo ma non ti ho
chiesto di fare questo ti devi attaccare
bravissimi gli attacchi a quello dopo
facendo un giro dalla parte opposta sono
t agganci male bravo questo ti ho
chiesto di fare questo hai fatto ora vai
giù pianissimo perché non stai andando
giù se io ho visto che non è andare giù
molto bene no mi fa fare quello che
voglio fare
vi facciamo non ho assolutamente detto
di fare questo ma lui ha fatto questo
vabbè non lo finiremo mai siamo solo se
manca solo l'antenna solo questa foto
dante solo l'antenna manca solo questa
solo l'antenna manca
solo l'antenna
secondo me l'hanno modifico vi giuro che
la prima volta che ho fatto l'antenna
l'ho fatta in 30 secondi
neanche forse venti come ho fatto visto
che ora in mezz'ora non sono mai
riuscito a farla è stranissimo ve lo
giuro veramente strano perchè fai questo
non ti ho chiesto di fare questo perché
fai così
assurdo che costa facendo del tappo dai
regali finale righetti ingo veri li
mortacci nia per i 5 milioni o no perché
perché fai così non si ho chiesto di
fare così tutto anche sto dicendo di
fare questa cosa
ok ok vedi che sismica tutto non capisco
[Musica]
riavvio il gioco come fattorino perché
secondo me dopo un po si sismi no no no
no no no non è questione di vedere come
si fa la parte finale si fa così la
parte finale di getting over è una
cagata mostruosa pazzesca solo non
funziona perché non si sa se non si
attacca io non sono agitato non sono
agitato non fa quello che gli dico e
basta guardando ai stai calmo non sto
facendo niente
doveva è pazzo sul finale diventa pazzo
guardalo cosa minchia fly
ma chi te l'ha chiesto io vista guarda
guarda si vuole a caso c'è il finale
così il finale è così
non so perché sul finale il martello
inizia a fare quello che cazzo vuole
non capisco il motivo giuro è
difficilissimo per questo motivo è una
cosa è una difficoltà a giunta perché
prima non c'era
e non capisco perché fino adesso la band
ma avete visto come ha giocato fino al
secchio della montagna che faccio schifo
però avete visto no perché adesso una
cosa così banale come questa perché
l'antenna e banalissima tv solo
appendere dei guarda guarda dove vai
cosa succede dove vai perché non solo io
di questo lo fa lui da solo e perché
loro vi dico che pur non sto impazzendo
è lui che scemo non so cosa succede nel
finale di questo gioco non so cosa sia
successo ma da un po e a passo
sensibilità si perosa basso si metta di
nuovo mi stavo cadendo si abbassò
sensibilità mi muovo troppo lento non
riesco la via di mezzo c'è la costa via
di mezzo quindi non posso
dopo l'aceto scusatemi se non michele
galasso in concentratissimo premiati o
c'è qualche me devo fare
no si è ovvio che sia successo sì mi ha
dato mandato no
l'opa 37 e fa tutte montagne
people of the internet and that's all
folks quota player tutto getting over it
in un'oretta un'oretta 10 di cui 20
minuti il 90 per cento del gioco e 50
minuti tutor il finale era una o il
finale l'antenna di getting over it è
una cagata è una cagata l'altro tipo sta
andando dal creatore per dirgliene
quattro
il finale che ti vorrei e una cag la
l'antenna è una le cose più semplici
rispetto a tutto il gioco è una cagata
in un boh non so perché e o sono io che
ciò il m la mano alla fine perché di
chimica incredibile tipo come quando fai
il roland garros e cioè il match point
che tremavano e dennis è uguale non lo
so però vi giuro vi giuro che non so
come mai e verso la fine io sono sempre
avuto problema o è un problema mio
il gioco che proprio aggiunge la
difficoltà nella gravità non lo so cosa
c'è però il finale non riesco a fare pur
essendo una cagata no perché la montagna
è difficile secchi difficile di orange l
difficile ok fila che l'antenna è una
cagata incredibile come ha fatto non
riuscirci anche l'altra volta
impossibile rega questo è tutto che tipo
verità dall'inizio alla fine nota gli
uncut un'ora e dieci sono contentissimo
sono contentissimo grazie a tutti per
partecipato a quanto siano rischi
assolutamente concitato e non mi sono
ricordato appunto siamo rotti ne mancano
cattiva 5.000 cinquemila iscritti 5000 è
qualcosa in tempo reale io le vedo nel
live count 5.000 iscritti mancano regalo
vinto io me li merito iscrivetevi tutti
un secondo account immediatamente veli
merito ho vinto ghetto finito che ti ngo
riti in una live e vi farò vedere che
cosa c'è
se finisci che ti ngo veri se tieni il
tuo nome
quello che a 5 milioni che a 5 minuti al
5 non lo fa metterlo cromo fa scrivere
perché ho vinto ho vinto sucate questo è
quello che succede ti fa arrivare in una
specie di chat dove tutti i vincitori di
getting over it possono scrivere io ci
sono arrivato adesso ho scritto più di
guai su sky with you di fi drive
arrivata adesso gli scrive subscriber
subscriber truffa vj b case isner stoffa
e million now thank you
signori questa è la getting over it
questi erano penseranno le mie skill
sono riuscito a farlo in live tutto sono
bravissimo sono stato veramente molto
bravo sono contento niente lascio questa
live
lascio questa live in evidenza su
youtube no
la rinomina o anche getting over it in
un'ora e mezza più o meno anche se ci ho
messo un po di meno un circa un'oretta e
adesso parto con un'altra live per fare
rock plico con thomas però questa live e
la voglio salvare a parte quindi ci
mette un po per partire con la seconda
live se non mi riparte di nuovo in
questa perché questa la voglio salvare a
parte perché la live di getting over it
dove l'ho iniziato e finito nella stessa
live peccato che ci ho messo sei ore dal
secchio in poi però sono riuscito a
farcela quindi ben ali finisco questa
live
ci rivediamo per chi vuole vedere loket
league tra 5 minuti
riparto con l'utente va bene faccio
quello che gli batte cui proprio grazie
adriana app vi leggo tutti e adesso vi
nego tutti nella prossima alibi leggo
tutti quelli che ho mandato a donazioni
iscrivetevi al canale con secondo
account perché me lo sono meritato
riportarci mia
iscrivetevi quel primo secondo terzo
account di collegare turco fido getting
over it in live maledizione
se volete la la juve finisce qua se
invece volete continuare la ride
continua su rocket league
nella successiva faccio partire un'altra
live e proprio a parte ok però i video
vi sia piaciuto come se vi è piaciuta
c'è un documento mi piace anche al
comitato descrizione che se siete vi è
anche quei secondi account
lc vediamo un prossimo video un po più
tranquillo senza martelli e pentole
uomini calvi bella ragazzi